boyfriend is a really like emotional
support really good [ __ ] if you if
you you hope you want that yeah because
the husband's very average [ __ ]
that's all it is right it goes down once
you get married that sounds like a great
tender problem
[Music]
welcome back to another careful boys
where we are very careful careful we are
extending this is part two of a
conversation we had but this is probably
seven months later so uh Joe Ryan this
is about what tools are keeping us from
being men would you say is that is that
I would say what's everyone's definition
of like that man because it was inspired
by Ryan's idea of like oh I don't feel
like I'm yet man enough or like husband
material enough and I was like trying to
figure out what he meant by that and I
realized that all guys have a different
definition of what that is and also I'm
glad that Colleen's here because females
would have a different definition of
what they think that epitome of a man or
a husband material is because a lot of
the times you know guys would think the
man is someone who has a nice ass car a
ton of money and then like he has a lot
of girls right but then a lot of girls
will look at that and be like oh that
guy is just peacocking he's coming
covering up he's actually a little [ __ ]
so I'm like I don't have a lot of sense
would say that too and a lot of sense
would say that a lot of sips
a lot of Sims would say that's the man
yeah
Are we more specifically on like almost
uh the uh Evolution from like a
boyfriend to a husband I think that's
yeah that's more what it is yeah yeah
let's do that because like boy the man
is like that's like whoa no it's
definitely more boyfriend because at
some point you have to think about that
like it's not a transition that just
takes care of itself I don't think I
think you have to take accountability at
one point and go like hey if I'm really
in it for this person then the skills
kind of have to take a different
direction you know totally because a
husband in my opinion is someone who is
life building family building future
like lifelong partner that you're
committed to boyfriend is a really like
emotional support really good [ __ ] if
you if you you hope you want that yeah
because the husband's very average
[ __ ] that's all it is right it goes
down once you get married that sounds
like a great gender problem
you would hope the boyfriend it starts
with good [ __ ] and it dwindles over
the years it gets whack it gets whack or
like the play stage I would say is the
boyfriend stage you have a lot of fun
it's the initial You're Building all of
those things together
but I don't know I think there's a lot
of understanding too because uh great
boyfriends don't necessarily make good
marriages and um and I think like it's
it's what you're paying attention to
it's like almost like the the point
right in between is your last
like portion to really see if you can
truly uh understand this person
and if you have the capacity to really
like see what they're saying when
they're saying it that way you don't run
into the old basic problems like why did
you say it like that why did you mean it
this way they were fighting about year
one [ __ ] and that shouldn't happen in
the marriage I don't think I think you
should there's enough real problems in a
marriage that you could probably put
away the [ __ ] schoolyard [ __ ] you
know yeah but that's probably why
there's a lot of divorces too because
there are people that still fight like
that in their 40s yeah exactly yeah well
there's also like yeah there's a lack of
emotional intelligence but one of the
things that you know I don't know if
you're one of those guys Ryan you're you
seem like a very uh particular person as
far as like getting [ __ ] done like I
think most compliment yeah but no but
really like I think maybe um when it
comes to like you're you want to be a
good husband like I almost think you're
gonna be a great husband because you're
like over preparing now yeah like like I
remember when I was making that
transition like I literally got married
and I was like okay I'm gonna look up
because I Love My Chick so much I'm
gonna look up
the number one things that guys do that
like ruins relationships on BuzzFeed
yeah on break.com
and it was really simple like three
lists so I could read it quickly right
so uh so no it was like it was dude
household chores like not participating
household chores was like the [ __ ]
number one thing it's like money and
households are you serious dude not
participating like being a [ __ ] lazy
[ __ ] right and so I just started
attacking that game like never before
and I and Nikki like immediately knows
she's like man she's like we got married
and like Steve just started like [ __ ]
doing dishes all goddamn time and stuff
I don't have to ask him and like I just
started to make that part of like my
awareness and like because I think when
as guys we we want to do things but
we're not always like thinking of it
like priorities wise yeah we're like oh
yeah well that's bottom of my list
because that's that can get done it's
just my own house unless people are
coming over right yeah then we heighten
it on the priorities list we don't think
about what your person goes through when
they see their house and like go oh
disarray disrespects my house and [ __ ]
you know you just you don't know right
right so that's when I started to nip
that in the butt but in progress right
like like I think I got better like as I
took that next step and maybe you're
just preparing like [ __ ] crazy like
when you're playing when you play like
um a strategy game you build a [ __ ]
massive massive Army before you take
over the map and I just do slowly little
bits at a time I also think the idea of
like
um even taking on those household chores
is so impactful at that time because
after the official Union is when that
house becomes both of yours you know
what I mean right right before you might
be roommates like housemates you know
what I'm saying uh and and if it's not
official then you know like you've
probably already experienced whether it
be through college or anything else you
know like living with other people so so
just adjusting your your system
preferences of like how you live is
um a thing that can happen with uh
non-romance Partners right whereas the
second you become like official official
it's like everything is shared
everything belongs to you like both the
responsibilities and the actual material
things like everything like if I bought
that TV when uh we were boyfriend and
girlfriend after we're married it's like
that's half yours too you know what I'm
saying uh and same with the dishes the
same with the whatever so I think
household chores are actually a very
significant thing
when it comes to understanding that that
house is now both of yours I think it
helps when you operate the same way like
you have the same lifestyle like if
you're both clean well this is going to
be easy operation
maybe find that in a partner what is
that but is it that sweet if they're
already that way or is it kind of sweet
if they're working harder oh
yeah working harder and accomplishing it
great working harder and not I don't
know well yeah accomplishing it
absolutely
I think it's um
you can get the point across like if you
want some chores done a certain way
but not say it so [ __ ] mean
they'll people are more likely to do it
yeah so like so like let's say um you
know Hannah says it jokingly and I get
the point it doesn't really hurt me but
then I'm like oh that's that makes a lot
of sense and we can laugh about it but
there's some people that just are so
[ __ ] mean why don't you do this
that's because you [ __ ] suck yeah and
it's like or like they're like in like
maybe they're hurt and offended because
like you mentioned it's like oh they
feel disrespected because you are
inconsiderate so they come at you as if
you were really trying to hurt their
feelings and then it causes like this
it's just very combative and then it's
like man that that makes people want to
be defensive and not want to do it at
all then so and I think like that like
the initial approach always has to be
like if you're gonna tell somebody to do
something do it
yeah do it with kindness like you are in
a in a you guys are a couple but what if
you got to tell them to do it 55 times
then it's gonna kind of then you have to
also accept that you gotta probably tell
them a hundred more times too and you
can start posting notes yeah I did read
this one thing right out of all places
um I follow this um Instagram called men
ask men Reddit and there's this one part
that said what like makes your marriage
successful and then this guy or I forgot
who they were but they were like no
matter what your partner does stuff for
you
just be thankful that it's done who the
[ __ ] cares like how it was done and I
was like oh yeah you know what that's
true it's done and it's and it's work
that you wouldn't have you know had the
time to do anyways yourself you have a
partner that now that does it for you
you just trade your expectations for
appreciation and your problems start to
go away a little bit Yeah and and then
for me I I was like oh well I what's
preventing me from just doing it before
them if I wanted done a certain way so
then it's like oh like let's say the
dishes were done a certain way where I
didn't like it well I could have done
the dishes why do I have to tell them to
do it yeah so I'm like I don't know if
you're gonna be anal about it it's like
then just do it your way yeah do it my
way and then yeah so then there's a lot
of problem solving like that that I
think couples would probably blame and
tell the other person to do when it
could have just been prevented from
themselves so I think it's a lot of
those kind of things like when you
become more and more committed like you
run into these like everything is like a
negotiation everything is like who does
what and how do they do it and then I
think that if the love is lacking there
then it's always like a me against you
versus like oh how do we just do and
it's not that big of a deal it never is
it's like dishes it's like
cleaning it's like laundry it's like why
are you [ __ ] ruining your whole life
just for that happy holidays people's
today's video is brought to you by Warby
Parker what better time than now to try
on some glasses for free before you
purchase maybe you have a face profile
just like your friend that you want to
get glasses for what's awesome about
Warby Parker is I went online
I clicked around the website picked out
some glasses and I was like I do want to
buy these maybe but I'm not too sure
because I don't know if it's gonna look
good on my face so I ordered the fine
and these are the five
and Warby Parker has everything you need
for happier eyes
eyeglasses sunglasses contact lenses and
eye exams and you could shop with them
online or in stores glasses start at 95
including prescription lenses try Warby
Parker's free home try on program order
five pairs of glasses to try on at home
for free there's no obligation to buy it
ships for free and it also includes a
prepaid shipping label so you could just
send it right back if you don't want it
so try five pairs of glasses at home for
free at warbyparker.com off the Record
like that's the weird part it's probably
because she most women uh well in my
experience as well is they take it out
on those small little things but there's
a underlying issue yeah that's probably
which is usually bad sex yeah I know I'm
not digging her down hard enough could
be could be like they need just for the
sake of getting off the subtopic of like
household chores and stuff um I think
there's there's also this really uh
there's such a mental shift you know in
terms of like trying to evolve to become
like husband material um in certain
things like uh the culture of even at
like a wedding a father like giving
their daughter away that's also
literally like you assuming that mantle
uh of being like the protector and
provider of that person as well you know
it's very traditional in uh in culture
and thought but
it's something as uh daily as you
remember how like every every single
time whether it be like going to a field
trip or like you know admitting yourself
to like a a doctor or whatever you
always got to put yourself uh put out
like an emergency contact and you know
it's like for my whole life I'm usually
putting like my sister or like my dad or
something like that right and then the
second you think about like
um is somebody gonna
put me as their emergency contact moving
forward you know what I mean whether
whether it be something as like a lost
item to like uh you know death you know
like you're the person that's going to
be called to like be the number one
person like handle somebody else's life
suddenly oh my gosh I don't have a car
anymore
as a boyfriend it's like I'm trying to
be the best version of myself and and
like uh
you know just
in that way but like as a as a husband
it's like you have to be that best
person for somebody else as well and I
think being ready for that is a very
mental thing as well it's not just like
a number of lists of actions that I
should do to be better it's like also
just being having that mental strength
and fortitude and and being able to
shoulder that responsibility in in the
seriousness of it you know what I mean
because becoming somebody else's
emergency contact is like huge it's a
big deal that's a huge deal I I think um
that's a big ask
I don't know if I can make it dude
honestly whoa it didn't just put me in a
[ __ ] grinder over here I'm like I'm
like oh [ __ ] I don't have a car so if
sneaky has the car I mean contact that's
going to be a real [ __ ] problem you
can go Uber fast though you're really
good yeah
you guys ever like see your parents
um relationship and go like you know
what that I'm not gonna do for real so
so like yeah so my biggest thing was
Finance for I was like I never want to
burden my partner with the lack of being
able to survive yeah and I saw the
stress that my family had of like so
like even though I've been
like
at a loss of money I've never been broke
meaning like I never lost my roof I
never lost being able to eat I've never
lost your truck bed
we could sleep in that we could sleep in
anything right but still the the concept
behind it was I always felt like the
epitome of a good man or like a husband
is someone who can provide and I think
my father failed at that like he
couldn't provide so I'm like that's the
basic probably
thing that a husband can do if you think
traditionally like what is what is a man
supposed to do is be responsible
at least with working and paying bills
but if you get sick and whatever that's
a circumstance of life it's not you
being
um incompetent and I think being
incompetent means like you failed so I
think that to me was one of my biggest
things like I gotta make sure no matter
what like I live in a decent place
decent enough to where it's safe and
comfortable yeah
well for me it's like a
how I used to try to look at everything
like I was super scared when we got
married in a lot of weird ways like not
because I didn't feel like I was ready
for it but it was just like a lot of
responsibility that I didn't necessarily
think I could do at that time you know
but it's more of like you just kind of
grow into the role like it's it's it's
uh
my mindset was just like how do I just
unburden things from my partner like how
do I just make it easier just across the
board whether it's living at home
whether it's like hey if she's cooking
once a night I'll try to cook as much as
I can because I'm not going to be at the
house it's obviously it's really
dependent on like work and everything
you have on your plate but um yeah like
I think that's the only thing that kind
of kept me thinking
like making me feel safe in that way
like this is like I can control this I
can control how I could help around the
house how I could just make her life
easier and she does the same thing for
me in a lot of ways too so it's like a
we we didn't get that much friction like
when we moved in together when we got
married which I feel very thankful for
because it's like I realize our
Situation's not like everyone else is in
in certain aspects but just like
having that open line of communication
of like what do you need as a human
being what are your expectations out of
a marriage because everyone's going to
have different expectations everything's
going to have different wants so
understanding what that partner wants
and if that's something that you can
deliver you're which I'm assuming you'll
be fine at like it'll be not a big deal
like if I can get married and have a
relationship for more than two three
years like you'll be fine you'll be fine
you try so [ __ ] hard dude I feel like
Ryan you always try to outdo yourself
and like you're out doing yourself I
don't think some people could ever reach
Ryan's a [ __ ] doomsday prepper over
here but it's also it's like just for
anniversaries yeah like just the thought
process and then the execution
afterwards it's just most people don't
even have the thought process I don't
even remember my anniversaries
think about that oh yeah dude yeah so
the fact that you're already thinking
about that alone
you keep me on the Spectrum like I get
confused when I'm around you no there's
like I think there's like a generational
difference between how our dads were
in a way like that's the fear in it you
know like and there's and not that like
my dad had bad qualities but like he he
just had so many things that I thought
were default I'm like how are you good
at all these like things in terms of
like solving practical problems like
fixing [ __ ] uh you know like building
things like he just one day I woke up
and he built like a whole [ __ ] patio
I was like you don't even do this he
could Farm you know but that's like his
life was completely different than mine
I get it but like different skills I
think in the now age I I feel like the
skills that we got that are default to a
guy like him like he looks at me and
he's like wow how did you fix the
computer it's like yeah you know I know
there's different ones but then um I
feel like I I am a little bit afraid
that in the world to come that I'll see
that I'm missing the ones that my dad I
could have learned from him and I could
have saw that and went oh like I should
know how to do that I should like learn
that because you know they're there but
I I sort of missed it because I was so
preoccupied with getting good at today's
type of [ __ ] yeah but imagine it's like
your son's birthday in the future and
then you [ __ ] remake like Final
Fantasy for him and he's the main
characters like that and then he goes to
school and all the [ __ ] kids are
jealous I I think you have enough skills
to to add value to your relationship I
just want to learn to cook more things
you tell me you can't figure out how to
make a patio I bet you could it'll look
like [ __ ] the first time I think yeah
exactly do you guys think Ryan's kind of
like humble bragging a little bit right
now yeah a little bit because he's like
he's like he's like yeah I could
probably program a new game or like you
know insert my kid into the space
program but um I can't cook an omelette
I'm insecure about it guys it's that
thing of like getting really good at
things and then knowing that there's not
really a place maybe where that will be
what saves my marriage do you think she
cares enough about you not cooking for
it to be such a big problem we're not
building patios
but I think it's it's because I'm
self-aware that throughout my life
I am I'm a Serial uh I'm really good at
at uh impressing the girl I'm good at
like getting them interested and I
haven't always been the best at
sustaining and that's like something
that like okay I [ __ ] understand that
like I have like a really great opener
you know what I mean six years later in
two Studios together seems like a pretty
good and you know and that's and I think
that was big that was a big uh asset
because we in terms of like working
together as a couple that's great when
it's new to both of you because I can't
really talk [ __ ] and go like I know how
to do it let me do it like we both don't
know anything and that was a really good
thing to bring us closer because I
wasn't I like that thing I was telling
you where like as a guy you tend to
[ __ ] Zone in on these teachable
moments and go yeah you know now that
you know let me tell you how it goes you
know and like I [ __ ] had to really
get rid of that because it's a bad
[ __ ] male habit yeah but like that
you know what I mean it helped a ton to
also be clueless make mistakes together
yeah she can talk equal amount of [ __ ]
for something that looks stupid bid that
we both did you know like it that was a
big cure for I think complexes that I
had for years but if you can have a
business with your like partner and
lover like that's already a huge you're
basically married yeah you're basically
yeah you're like yeah yeah in California
what when you live together for what
over five years your domestic
partnership she could leave with half of
everything you got that means your van
well she keeps like I'm just kidding me
half a Quest Crew just let me keep the
card outside
also think there's an underrated thing
that because when you're in a marriage
right or a relationship at all Partners
grow and sometimes they don't grow
together and and so I think being
malleable for their growth is really
important like I remember when Nikki
like me and Nikki used to go to
steakhouses and we would [ __ ] up some
steaks and like like that was like our
celebration thing like any time that
either of us had a win like a
significant win we would go get some
steaks right
and then she is like I don't want to eat
meat anymore and I'm like all right but
like you can have nugs sometimes
like it was a transition period but I
just I just forget like because it's
early it was early days and I hadn't
like I think really accepted that that
this was like gonna stick yeah but it
was like a growth moment for her like
where she's going she's like doing her
thing right and then I think you know I
used to make these like I still make
them I used to make these tacos like
with [ __ ] beef or whatever or ground
turkey and I I was like doing Taco
nights with her and stuff and then I
think the day that I was like Hey the
tacos are all vegan today was a day
where she was like oh [ __ ] like he gets
it like it's all locked in now and then
yeah but yeah growing with your person
like changing your tradition so that it
still fits to where they're going growth
wise very important thing I think yeah
effort matters even the little things
yeah yeah
man
this is a deep one huh no we don't have
deep conversations anymore right Joe